I came here in 1956.  UCLA needed someone
to take over on the teacher education program.
The salary was terrible compared with anything.
If I told you, you wouldn't believe me.It was so low.
But I said I'd rather be here because I thought
I could have more influence.
And when I came here, it's been a tremendous opportunity.
At the beginning when I came here there were 50 members of the School of Education.
Now those 50 were scattered in every department.
And what they were charged to do in their departments, in addition to their subject matter,
they had to help the students learn how to make
that subject matter meaningful
for children--students--in the school.
And then I would put them in various schools
for practice teaching.
And I would help them write their lesson plans
and curriculum for the semester.
This was really a training school for LA City teachers.
That's what it was.
But, what is education? We don't know yet.
That's our topic right now in the United States.
Right in this building.
What what do we mean by education?
What should it be?
Preparing just for a job?
Preparing for intellectual enlightenment?
What does it mean for your children?
What do you want them to be if they're educated?
I just love to see what students can do when you...
The main thing is opening up a opportunity
for them to learn and to teach us.
I've enjoyed that more than
anything I think. I've really enjoyed it.